alright guys bangbang the Alex here I'm
super excited to do this this is a round
two my friend you ready to go I'm ready
to go crippled non crippled whatever way
I'm ready let's um let's start off with
for those that didn't listen to the
first episode or don't remember maybe
just give us a quick two minutes on on
your background and what you're doing
with amber so two minutes I guess I'm a
I would fit into the camp of you know
toxic Bitcoin maxi's or whatever the
hell they're you know categorizing
ourselves today I think the last podcast
that you and I did we were talking about
the importance of Bitcoin as being you
know this intolerant minority standing
in the middle and you know and not not
giving ground and I think that's an
extremely important function of um of
any of any system you know there's got
to be a group of people who just won't
Bend and I think that's what you know
III kind of aligned with those Bitcoin
as the most and you know through that
you know I really think that coins the
most important thing happening in the
world today and my you know I've got a
philosophical expression of that through
doing the writing and podcast and all
that sort of stuff but my
entrepreneurial expression of that is a
little product called amber and amber is
designed to be a Bitcoin accumulation
app so I kind of differentiate it from
you know the coin basis of the world
it's um it's not a trading app you know
it's not designed for you to sort of you
know trade [ __ ] coins or you know like
it's not or to you know buy and sell and
all this sort of stuff it's really
designed to accumulate Bitcoin in a in a
fashion that's as automated as possible
so we kind of led the whole DC a move
and there's a lot of people now doing DC
a and we're doing some cool things now
with with we're going to introduce a
premium feature to Amber that alarm
that'll make sat stacking smarter more
automated and cheaper over
so we are we're investors I don't even
know that yet we just did and so give us
an update just kind of any metrics or
data so we would know how it's going yes
so so we're in we're in AWS at the
moment we've got almost 5000 users there
we're about to roll out I guess
I'm putting the final touches here on
this Europe situation which is proven to
be you know interesting at the very
least dealing with you know compliance
and banking and all that sort of stuff
so we're down to now selecting the bank
that we're going to partner with which
is good so very shortly we'll be able to
deliver this now to Europe I'm hoping
for June that's the plan and Yemen will
be able to really deliver a nice clean
way for people to to accumulate Bitcoin
in a broader region and then from there
we're just like I want to hit South
Africa and then want to look at some
other markets as well for sure and so
the the big debate right now or
conversation is we are what seven eight
days away from the bitcoin having mm-hmm
and this has historically been a major
moment I'll go as far as a historic
moment what's kind of your general
thoughts about the having and how that's
going to kind of affect the entire
industry yeah look I I am I read an
article recently you know about the
halving and just sort of talking a
little bit about you know I wanted to
take a different spin on all the
conversations going on and around the
having so obviously Plan B really
brought the term that the concept of the
having to the fall with the stock flow
model and all of that sort of stuff and
I think a lot of the conversation has
been really around price and price
targets and you know this model about
you know how to get rich tomorrow by
buying Bitcoin and that's fine because
you know bitcoin is a it's a monetary
beast right so the more capital we get
flowing into this thing the better and
it just makes it stronger but
what i what i kind of wanted to focus on
was the this divergence in philosophy so
you know the world we live in today has
become you know one of more more more
now-now-now with you know blind access
and complete disregard so like the
consequences of the cost of ethics and
the sustainability of the decisions we
made today which you know every decision
comes at a cost you know and that those
decisions that we make today are
generally at the at the expense of the
future so you know we've and covet has
been like a really another one of these
you know knee-jerk reactions you know my
Exponential's and you know taking things
to an extreme in the way we deal with
them because we're so easily triggered
and we we don't stop for a moment to
think about the longer-term
ramifications of anything we do and you
know here you've got this incredibly
symbolic event in the having you know I
kind of like to say that whilst the
world is you know doubling tripling and
going exponential the Bitcoin is you
know having and you know going towards a
finite you know end supply and and
that's such a divergence in philosophy
like you know here we are everything is
becoming abundant and you know cheap
whereas we've forgotten what is scarce
and valuable and you know Bitcoin kind
of stands alone as the the pillar of
you know traditional the traditional way
we are
we understand value you know something
that is unique you know I could use an
example of you know a fine piece of art
like you know that there is one Mona
Lisa or you know your mother you've got
one mother she's fundamentally valuable
to you because she's fundamentally
unique like if you could just print your
mum you know a thousand times like she's
not going to be as valuable so these
things are this is such an interesting
to me philosophical divergence and it's
just funny to see how the world is
forking at this point in time with you
know Bitcoin being this thing on one
side where and all the madness that's
happening on the other side so that
that's kind of how I envisioned the
having and um and I think it's yeah I
think this is probably the first having
like the last having was yeah you know
not many people knew about it I think
this is the first one that's getting a
bit of airtime I know my guess is 2024
it's gonna be like her it's gonna be
like one of those New Year's Eve events
you know that everyone's sort of
watching and counting down for it's
gonna be really interesting yeah one of
the best frameworks that I've heard for
this is while the world is quantitative
easing right and kind of expanding that
sheet that the balance sheet Bitcoin is
quantitative hardening yeah and to me
like that just puts this whole concept
in the same terminology that financial
experts know and understand all right
the people in the traditional world when
they look at it that way it's like okay
hold on a second quantitative easing
versed quantitative hardening one of
those sounds a lot better than the other
right absolutely and that's sort of that
that again ties up with you know easy
versus hard like you know there's
there's things in life like if you want
to be let's just take happiness as a
thing if you want to live a life of
happiness you can either go and grab
some heroin and start shooting up
and just you know being bliss the whole
time and you know probably die from an
overdose or you can take the hard road
which is live a life of meaning and to
live a life of meaning you're gonna have
to go through you know pain suffering
sacrifice lost emotion so it's gonna
build depth in your character it's gonna
build strength it's gonna you're gonna
grow as a human being and and that is
the harder path it's the you know it's
the path of the historic you know it's
um but it's it's sort of been drummed
out of society you know like where
everything has apparently got to come
easy
whether it's our money whether it's you
know the five minute abs or whatever
other [ __ ] is sold to us you know
the cheap plastic [ __ ] it's just it's
just crazy so I I really love Bitcoin
for for that shift in ideology I think
that's where we're not not enough of our
focus goes when we're thinking about
that coin well what do you think it's
gonna take for this to go from what I'll
call kind of a niche community in the
global world right
you know maybe 1% of the world's
population is even kind of using Bitcoin
bought Bitcoin whole Bitcoin and out of
that 1% no let's say 50% really really
understanding that's probably me being
generous right yeah kind of the the
framework and the in the difference what
does it take for that to grow on a
percentage basis so people who already
hold Bitcoin go from let's say 50
percent to closer to a hundred percent
but also how do we get from 1% of the
total global population to 10 percent
right and kind of I think of it almost
like a penetration of a market thoughts
there I think so I've got a the the the
pain and curiosity theory I kind of call
it so I think people come to Bitcoin for
two reasons pain or curiosity so
curiosity in the sense that you're
interested in what this technology is
you're interested in you know money I
guess you could probably
add a third one there greed you know and
greed I think gets a bad rap it's a it's
a greed is an interesting thing I've got
Gordon Gekko actually in my um in my
article where you know greed is actually
fundamentally good because it's a driver
for for human progress and it you know
helps us thrive now greed unchecked just
as anything else it's bad you know like
food is a good thing but if all you do
is eat all day you're gonna get fat
right so as with anything you know
there's a sensible there's a sensible
median but um I think greed curiosity so
those who are curious enough to want to
inquire about what is Bitcoin or what is
money or how is society shifting what's
going on you're gonna get into it but I
think unfortunately more people will
discover Bitcoin because of some level
of pain and maybe it maybe fortunately
unfortunately I don't know but that's
not I guess my place to judge but I
think that the pain piece is probably
you know going to be the the largest
driver and that maybe pain from I don't
know watching your currency collapse
like what's happening in Lebanon now
watching you know your own personal
finances collapse so let's say you're
you know living in America at the moment
and you're forced to stay home against
your will even though you're young fit
healthy and you have a very minimal
chance of some invisible buyers coming
to get you
but you're forced to stay home and go
broke and you get given some measly
little twelve hundred you know US dollar
check and that's apparently gonna last
ten weeks right you know so so you know
that pain is gonna drive you to say well
this is [ __ ] [ __ ] and then you
know what whilst that's happening on one
side you know the prices of your goods
are going up because production stopped
and money is losing its purchasing power
so so at some point something's gonna
snap in either way you know I need to
something's gonna drive so it's kind of
like a carrot and a stick you know the
the carrot is probably the the curiosity
in greed and the stick is the pain and
as we know throughout society and
throughout history it's usually the
stick
that drives the most change and I think
we're just sort of lucky in the period
of time that we live in that we have
something like Bitcoin as a as an exit
strategy for that because people in the
past haven't had this yeah and this
isn't like academic theory right like
we're literally seeing this play out in
Lebanon right now yeah right we're
literally the national currency has lost
you know almost 50 percent of its its
purchasing power in a very short period
of time the bank's implemented all kinds
of capital controls so you can withdraw
a certain amount every day they won't
let you withdraw and any currency other
than the Lebanese currency and then on
top of that it's during the coronavirus
where people have lost their jobs and so
what ends up happening is people
literally go to sleep when they wake up
in the morning they have two questions
how much of my wealth did I lose
overnight because I walk because I lost
actual purchasing power and them two is
do I have enough money to go buy
groceries because at the same time that
you're losing the value of your currency
food prices and other prices are going
up yeah exactly it's mental absolutely
mental what is the catalyst do you think
like we're the tipping point where we go
from you know it's happening in Lebanon
right now and I genuinely believe most
people they want to be happy and they
want to have some level of freedom right
at the end of the day that's what they
want and that manifests itself in a
whole bunch of different ways of life
but ultimately they want to be able to
spend time with their loved ones be free
you know not have to worry about access
to food or shelter in kind the basic
needs of human life but if the current
system makes that hard we see it on a
micro level do we have to wait for that
to happen on a macro level where it's
happening in multiple kind of global
superpowers in order for people to wake
up and shift over or can we go kind of
population by population and slowly but
surely you get some people who say hey I
don't want to you know participate in
this Lebanese pound mirage anymore I'm
gonna opt out I'm gonna opt out I'm an
opt-out and then after decades you get
kind of a majority of people who have
opted out well
I was writing a piece yesterday I
released my little piece called
correcting Dalia after his little second
chapter that he wrote about changing
world powers in any eye one of the
sections are eroding there was about
these this idea of a phase shift so if
we think about water for example you
know it's got you know these three
primary forms that it comes in solid ice
liquid water and gas steam right and you
know as the temperature increases and
you know it it remains in its state but
there's something happening you know at
a molecular level that's sort of
basically invisible and then you have
this situation where it's like slowly
slowly slowly but all at once and then
the the phase shifts and my guess is
that society is probably very similar in
that sense is you know we you know you
had this undercurrent of change you know
that sort of like the zeitgeist of the
time that you know that it's happening
and because societal shifts are a much
longer in nature you know and I'm not
talking about dahlias 17-year debt cycle
I'm talking more like societal shifts of
like you know the separation of church
and state five hundred years ago you
know now we're sort of seeing the
separation of money and state like did
this is a this is a multi-year
multi-decade transformation but you know
that that sort of phase shift period I
think you know has an undercurrent but
at some point and I think Conor Brown
used to have this on his uhm on his
Twitter profile it's like slowly but all
then all at once it's I think that's
gonna be the situation where it starts
to cascade and you know I mean when is
anyone's guess like the touch on
something there
this
[ __ ] wheels are going with this
I had a point so I think part of it
though is just like the gradually but
then all at once or slowly but then
suddenly I think is another one like
Unchained guys use that the idea really
comes down to what are the accelerant
and at some point do you hit a point of
no return right like I caught like
burning the boats right in the whole
idea of burning the boats is when you go
and you find new land you know back in
the day you're not actually committed to
staying until you burn the boats when
you burn the boats but you can't go back
right so when do we get to that point
well here we are burning the boats right
now I think Ovid was an example of
burning the boats right it's you know we
we just burnt the you know the the
interest rate boat then we burnt the QE
infinity boat so so those two boats are
burnt now what else is that like the
number of boats that are available to
burn to basically discredit the existing
system you know becoming less and less
numerous I mean I always say Kovan was
the one of the best marketing campaigns
for Bitcoin in history because like that
these are the events that I just
remember what I was gonna be analogy I
was gonna use earlier was on the
smartphone analogy like we can all
remember a time before smartphones like
when we all had flip phones or their
shitty Nokia banana phones and all that
sort of stuff we remember the dumb
phones and we remember when that was
ubiquitous and we also remember when you
know modern times now like when smart
phones are completely ubiquitous but
that transition period I can't exactly
remember that I don't really I'm not
really clear on when we had like a real
good mix of smart phones and dumb phones
at the same time like that had that
phase shift like happened so quickly and
I think you know we were obviously not
at that point yet with Bitcoin but I
think over the next decade the the
question is gonna shift from you know
people asking today's like why the hell
would you have Bitcoin to sometime in
the next decade the question will be why
the hell don't you have Bitcoin like
so that strange look like that that the
question will change and I mean
maybe maybe the trigger is gonna be
something as crazy as other a friend of
mine is another Bitcoin er in Australia
Hosmer kook he he put a tweet out a
little while ago saying my prediction
for next year is 40,000 in the Dow and
40% unemployment and that that to me
like I mean as crazy as that sounds like
what we're seeing right now with these
supposed solutions to the coded problem
is you know this printing of money
bailing out of the big boys and all the
sort of stuff is we're actually tearing
society apart and we're you know we have
this illusion of prosperity in the stock
market you know basically the Nasdaq
almost back at all-time highs
I mean Shopify blown through its high as
Amazon's blown through as high as Tesla
basically back at highs you know uber
and lyft the backup you know beyond
their December price it's such insanity
but at the same time we've got almost
30% unemployment who has nobody's
working
everyone's at home and you know
everyone's living on a $1,200
you know handout it's like it's some
Main Street and Wall Street are
completely diverging it's madness and
and maybe maybe that's what triggers
people to say you know I've had enough I
keep thinking about just like the virus
itself has done two things one its
accelerated a lot of trends one you just
mentioned of kind of the wealth
inequality gap right is definitely
getting accelerated right now but by
kind of the government's response to
this virus but also the virus has
exposed many shams in society right
whether it's higher education and you
know all the the kind of structure of
that or other things in the part to me
that I have I've talked very critically
about this and shied away from really
talking about it too much because it's
so sensitive but ultimately here in the
United States what we see is there's
federal income tax but if the government
can print whatever money they need why
are people paying taxes right it's kind
of like a business
saying like why do I actually charge the
customers when they come in if I can
just keep editing my bank account and
making my bank account have more money
in it like then I don't actually need to
sell anything I can just give away the
goods right I don't understand why am I
actually charging people for it
same thing here is like why is the
government charging federal income tax
if they can just print whatever they
want we're kind of thoughts there well
dude that's that's one of those boats
being burnt right it's um you know that
this idea that yeah it's it's funny that
you mentioned that because I was um
during this lockdown period I was stuck
with one person who's got a really
different viewpoint than me about you
know how the world works and they're
very kind of like call it a socialist
viewpoint right the government's gonna
save us all this was tough and then when
I sort of asked when I bring up this
point like I got her straight around to
my level of thinking I said so tell me
why he paying taxes and she explained ah
you know the hospitals and this and that
and I said we do realize that you know
more was just printed in a couple days
then taxes gathered in a couple years
- apparently bail us out so why don't
they just do that and build the
hospitals and it feels like that can't
be right
that that shouldn't happen like it so it
doesn't make actual sense when you think
about it for a second so it's I mean
this is this is the the issue I guess
that Bitcoin was originally designed to
solve a lot of people and this is where
I scratch my head up like the big hashes
and all the other crypto people who are
running around promoting faster payments
and all that sort of [ __ ] which is
nothing none of that matters when you
look at why Bitcoin was designed in the
first place which is to remove
concentrated control or concentrated
ability for the for the resource through
which we measure society to be managed
by someone so like when you remove that
then you can't play these games where
you know a business instead of selling
products just edits their bank account
like you know what we're doing is we're
disincentivizing real production
which is effectively the driver of
economies where we're taking that out of
the equation and we're just making
[ __ ] numbers up like how deranged did
this one have to be to think that this
is normal in no way is it normal but
that's not economics that's not society
that's not capital and the funny thing
is people try and call it capitalism
aspect that is not capitalism dude like
that that's not the definition of
capital and capital the definition of
capitalism is build capital through
production and through adding value and
through creating efficiencies whereby
you can you know create profit and
profit is just the measures how much
relative value you've added in or
relative input you've had in society
like that that's a good thing and people
are trying to sit here and you know
blame capitalism and support the
government just making up numbers in
their own ledger it's completely wild my
favorite way to articulate this is Marty
benzos fix the money fix the world right
and it literally has so many problems in
the world derive from this money issue
they do they do because here's the thing
like if money is the the board is is the
the board upon which we play the game of
life or the game of society
one player or a couple players can just
change the rules whenever they want but
the rest of us have to play by those
rules you tear apart the board like it's
no longer the same game we're playing
two different games and you're going to
be balanced the whole thing and and this
is what people don't get but the the
problem is that the guys who are get to
change the rules for themselves they're
actually part of a bigger game which
they can't get out of which is they live
you know in the same world as we do so
at some point when you tear apart the
fabric of society by distorting through
things like ayat we're gonna you know
you and I pump and everybody else is
listening to this we have to go out and
we have to trade our two finite
resources time and energy so that we add
value to society in order to be rewarded
with this unit called money where as a
couple people in society they get to
just make it up out of thin air you
start to break the game down and what
you end up doing is you create
ramifications such as forty thousand
down 40% unemployment like you basically
make the whole thing fall apart but once
the whole thing fall apart they
basically [ __ ] themselves over and they
forgive her and also over in the process
and it's just such a
I don't know short-term viewpoint it's
such a such an arrogant way of thinking
but unfortunately that that's what
happens when I mean when the needle is
so close right you know when you've got
a junkie and the temptation to feel good
is right there you know they're going to
use it so that the best solution is get
rid of the temptation altogether
throw it throw that out and that's you
know as Marty says fix the money you fix
everything so you throw the temptation
to [ __ ] with the fabric of society out
the window when that is out when you
cannot do it guess what your energies go
towards some form of productive action
and that starts to coalesce and converge
to a more structurally functional
society not one where you know a group
of people can change the rules in their
favor and so I guess as as part of this
then it happens all over the world it's
not just a u.s. thing it's not just kind
of a global superpower thing this
literally happens everywhere and so my
guess is that we're gonna see people
regardless of geography start the wake
up and slowly move at first Kobe
percentages of their wealth eventually
it'll be larger larger and even into the
majority over really decentralized
what is that infrastructure look right
now can we handle have another 2017 and
if not what do you think we need to
actually change or improve in order to
be ready for that that's a good question
okay so I think we're definitely ready
for another 2017 I think the you know
the unwraps are better you know there's
you know whether we're talking about
amber or whether we're talking about you
know the boy let's Swan a river and all
this sort of stuff there's there's a lot
better
Bitcoin onboarding services these days
so I think we can structurally have that
you know cigarettes you know broadly
adopted so you know we're not going to
get those ridiculous spikes and fees
while it's a smarter so you know you're
not going to get that so I think that's
fine I and I
I personally believe we'll probably see
a run you know later this year next year
in my mind again it's gonna be a price
driven run so I think this rise in
Bitcoin is going to be probably more
like if we think about those drivers of
you know paint curiosity greed it's
probably going to be another greed
driven driver at this point in time
because I think you know as much as
these stimulus packages and all this
sort of [ __ ] haven't solved the problem
they I think they've managed to at least
give a a sense of solution like it feels
like there's been a bandaid applied to
you know some of this apparent bleeding
so I think you know
Bitcoin fundamentally you know does have
the infrastructure from an onboarding
and from a functionality standpoint to
support another big run and yeah I think
it's really gonna kick off once we
passed the old all-time highs so once
bitcoins beyond twenty thousand what
we'll probably have is a period of
disbelief so maybe you know it crosses
twenty thousand people like you know oh
[ __ ] that Bitcoin things back at twenty
thousand are it's gonna fall again from
here and then I'll buy some and then
it'll you know probably reach 25,000
they'll be like oh I can't go any higher
than this you know this is another
bubble it'll hit 30 and I think that's
when we'll start to get some serious
FOMO and that's what's not to see you
know retail mark and all that sort of
stuff come in
that's what answer the question or I I
definitely think so what are you excited
about kind of Post having right so we're
coming into this event kind of how are
you thinking about once we get past that
and we looking forward to mm I I guess
p.m. the told-you-so moments so I think
the classic you know or all the the
Rabine ease of the world and all of that
sort of stuff we've just said that this
thing's gonna you know where they go to
zero or it's never gonna pass the old
time high it's just to chill above all
that sort of stuff I think that's really
and not from an arrogant place but just
from a rewarding place like you know
we've stood strong this entire time like
all the people who've stuck with it in
the bear market particularly the people
like you know that came in in 2016-2017
like this sort of you know we call it
the the class of you know this epoch
right it's um you know those the the
class that came before that was sort of
between 2012 and 2016 they've already
seen a bear market know that the the
people that have come in between 2016
and 2018 or between 2016 now have seen
this new bear market and
coming out of that on the other end and
sort of being proven right not to gloat
but to sort of inspire more people to
come in that's probably what I'm looking
forward to to the most because then they
guess what we we basically enlarge the
circle of toddlers of believers of that
critical mass of people that intolerant
minority that won't bend over or all
that won't go back to the old system
I was speaking to someone yesterday on a
FinTech podcast and you know I was kind
of just saying you know when I first got
into Bitcoin my idea was to sort of get
in and get out and make money and make
dollars now it's not no I'm trying to
gain territory on Bitcoin so if it means
like a one-way street I'm going in I'm
not coming back out like that you know
why would you you know move to a new
like place which is beautiful that has
everything you could one day need just
to move out again like it makes no sense
to me so like you know we're pioneers in
this new world and I think we're just
gonna miss post post Harvey is gonna
validate a lot of the things that we've
been saying to people for the last year
or two Oh longer one of the best ways
I've heard people talk about this is
everyone understands the concept of land
right they're not making more of it and
owning land has value if you can break
that model to bend that model to
understand digital land right or digital
property and you say hey there's only 21
million acres right and you can buy one
right now for eighty nine hundred
dollars
right do you think there's gonna be
worth more or less in the future right
yeah and and by the way look just like
land
there's price fluctuations sometimes
certain areas there it's more valuable
or less valuable right but generally
over long periods of time the scarce
assets rise in price and that has to do
with one there being more desirability
but also two it's actually the currency
being devalued against the scarce asset
right meaning that the US dollar or
whatever's is losing purchasing power
and so it takes more of those dollars to
buy that same asset and when people hear
that I think that kind of clicks and say
oh wait that is interesting explain that
more yes so we've got so you just
mentioned two forces there that that
basically are inversely correlated but
they drive each other which is the the
devaluing of the current currency that
we're using to price this new thing but
also the the scarcity and the fixed
supply of this new thing which can't you
know once people understand that it
can't be printed or you can't make more
of it you know the the common sense
thing is all right well infinite finite
you know that that's where more value is
then you've also got the arm in the
third piece like yeah you know let's
argue that someone could create
something that is finite in supply but
it's completely useless now that that
probably won't accrue value so like if
we look at Bitcoin it is fundamentally
useful you know it's digital divisible
portable it's got all these sorts of
incredible primitives another one that I
was discussing yesterday with someone
was and this is something I've
experienced firsthand as a fin tech
company for us for example to be able to
accept credit card payments to help
people buy Bitcoin then I am about two
and a half or three weeks through a due
diligence process with so much paperwork
so much checks so much garbage that like
I can't even explain to you how much
time and effort has been wasted just to
give us as a company the permission to
help somebody buy my product called
Bitcoin like if in a world where Bitcoin
is of functional money that permission
doesn't need to be you know chased like
you don't you don't have any of that so
all of that friction all of that wasted
time energy resources [ __ ] that doesn't
actually add value to anything it's gone
like you literally throw that out like I
think even Jack Dorsey was talking about
it he was saying you know square is a
thin tech company but it's fundamentally
unable to operate like an Internet
company because of all of these
jurisdictional limits that are exist
because of the current fragmented
you know horse-and-buggy financial
system that we have like Bitcoin is
completely an entirely different beast
it's that I mean coming back to a Peter
Thiel ism writers that it's the zero to
one it looks nothing like the existing
financial system and that therein lies
the innovation it's not you know all
these FinTech bros running around trying
to you know augment the existing
financial system and make some things
faster and you know you know build some
new api knows that's right that's all
cool and well you know it's it's cute
basically but it's not a fundamental
reinvention it's nothing new it's not
it's not an iPhone versus a Nokia banana
phone like it's it's a it's a complete
reinvention of money payments and all in
the one stack and that I think when you
layer that on top of the the land
argument and so you've got this thing
which is not ten times but a hundred
times more superior and then you say
it's finite in supply and then you say
that you can show that this other thing
that we're using at the moment is not
only infinite in supply but it's also
devaluing it's broken and all this sort
of [ __ ] but you you literally have to be
a maniac or a [ __ ] or ignorant or I
don't know what you have to be to sort
of dismiss bitcoiners for scan like like
I literally don't get it anymore
like it I see no reason why someone
shouldn't have not only you know some of
the wealth in Bitcoin but any wealth
that they actually value in Bitcoin
simple is that yes that's why I did get
off zero right I mean look we went
around the country on the United States
and even internationally just over and
over and over again
get off zero get off zero because
there's two things one is there's
obviously a exposure to the upside that
has a material impact on a portfolio but
two is once you have kind of skin the
game you start paying attention right
and and I literally used to tell people
take a hundred dollars put it in BIC
and think of it as you just invested in
an education cuz I don't think you'll
pay attention right I think that works
for people it works for absolutely
everyone like my mom who's got no
financial literacy whatsoever I got it
about some Bitcoin and I get these
random texts from like my mom is the
kind of person where when she saw um the
whole Libre news last year she was like
ah facebook is setting up their own
Bitcoin like that that's the kind of you
know comment that I would get from my
mom right but even she's like messaging
me saying ah you know that coins going
up again like it's just it's such an
interesting thing to see but but that's
that's what skin in the game does to you
right and so you know when you start to
yeah when you have some skin in the game
you've got something to burn and then
all of a sudden becomes important to you
you know when there's an ability to feel
pain and this is why pain receptors are
such an important piece of any system
like you know tying it back to this
whole covert thing and how you know
we're in a society now that wants to
eliminate any form of pain you know we
we feel a little bit sick we hid
ourselves with pain killers you know we
we we you know pain killers or
medication or antidepressants or you
know the economy is down a little bit
let's print more money let's
artificially drop interest rates like
all we're doing is we're
masking the problem we're slapping these
random band-aids over problems and every
single time you know particularly from
an economic standpoint I think that's
where we mess with things the most oh
maybe not maybe we mess with things
practically everywhere but every single
time these complex natural systems
biological economic or whatever try and
correct themselves try and come back to
their own natural equilibrium in we come
with some sort of intervention -
apparently fix it right like you know
these these interventions that people
say are so necessary like the market was
so overextended and not just talking
from a I the market needed a crash
you know standpoint but
everything was overextended like whether
you talk about supply chain and
just-in-time like there was no savings
there was stock buybacks for the sake of
stock buybacks all of this stuff was so
overextended and fundamentally the
economy needed to take a breath and
Corona was an opportunity to take a
breath and come back to some equilibrium
and therein that was the solution that
the fall was the solution and we've
somehow been taught that the the
correction or that fall or that crash is
the bad thing that the solution is
pumping more drugs into the system to
inflate it back up and it's become such
a backwards kind of you know level of
thinking because you know corrections
equilibrium pain death that they're
necessary in any system you know whether
at the cellular level the atomic level
through to the economic level through to
the societal level up through to the
interstellar you know cosmic level like
you know life and death there's
symbiotic and the more we try and avoid
death the more we try and avoid pain as
if it's a plague the more we actually
damage life you know Jordan Peterson
talks about this done the forest fires
you know forests have natural fires that
burn regularly all the freakin time
and by doing that you you know you have
these spores that are released you know
that only a release during these fires
more stuff then you know humans come in
and we're like ah fires are a bad thing
you know like a blanket statement we
stock the fires from happening and then
all of a sudden you have this one big
fire that comes and destroys everything
and not only burns everything down but
it burns the topsoil so now the forest
is a freaking desert and you've
destroyed it it's it's such a the more
you you play with these levers of a
complex system the more you have these
exogenous events that you are you just
can't measure and you actually destroyed
the system itself instead of allowing it
to correct and this is it's just it's
just crazy man
it's how systems function right it is
you kind of kind of let them do what
they do for the most part and the more
you interfere the more issues he can
cause well before we finish up I want to
spend some time you recently read a raid
a Leo's new chapter that he released
chapter two for his new book and he
wrote a pretty deep dive on basically
why you what do you think he got wrong
right so he spent a little bit of time
kind of talking through that may
mentioned it earlier but just you know
what your takeaways were and kind of
what do you think he got right well I
think so I'll hit on a couple pieces
number one he talks about you know
understanding money debt and credit and
all that sort of stuff but then you know
he he starts with that but then he gives
like such a really weak definition of
what money is he's like oh you know
money is a medium exchange and it's also
some some sometimes used as a store hold
of wealth I was reading that I'm like
what like you can't exchange something
that doesn't that's not you know
valuable in the first place so it's like
that you know it doesn't make sense and
I sort of argued that unless you give
you know a much deeper definition of
money the whole argument that is entire
chapter sits on just falls apart so you
know I kind of like to define money as
something deeper it's you know it's a
mechanism via which participants in
society can effectively collaborate like
if you don't have that mechanism Society
goes out the window you can't like you
know money is used to represent the
products of one's time and labor in
other words you know their work and any
if you don't get that depth you don't
appreciate how important money is and
then you can you know call it something
as stupid as I it's just the medium of
exchange so that's sort of where he
starts off then he starts talking about
you know you know yeah money doesn't
have intrinsic value blah blah blah but
then he turn
around and starts to talk about how gold
became money because it has intrinsic
value and then I was like facepalming
myself again I'm like okay
there's no such thing as intrinsic value
all value it's subjective simple of that
like and like that the example that I
like to use is you know we all value air
right like the ability to breathe but if
you have a child and you're both let's
say in a in a car accident and you fall
off a bridge and you're in the water and
only one of you is going to be able to
breathe what are you gonna value more in
that moment I know this is a brutal
example but you're gonna value air or
you're going to value your child's life
so it's it's a very what that means is
that at that point in time the value you
place on air is much lower than though
you place on you know your child's life
for example so it's all value is
subjective now Gould didn't become money
because of some notion of intrinsic
value it has specific attributes that we
converged upon as human beings to say
that hey that is a really good object to
represent the time and work that I'm
trading for money so that was another
area then there was a couple sections
that made him agreed on he talks about
how central banks are able to rig the
game then he's 100% right because that's
one of those things with I can see it
was highlighted in my article you know
whilst the rest of us idiots spend our
two finite resources time and energy to
to receive money in return you know
there's a few organizations who just
gets to change the rules for themselves
at the expense of the rest of us it's
just it's um it's madness then what else
did I hit things about where he talked
to you okay so he mentions a section in
there while the virus triggered this
particular financial and economic
downturn something else would have
eventually triggered it which I agree
with and regardless of what it did the
dynamic value would have basically been
the same because only intervention would
have worked to reverse the downturn
and I kind of really like poked at that
which is we didn't actually reverse the
downturn I actually think we've just
accelerated the downturn by intervening
again we didn't actually fix anything
we broke the [ __ ] even more than it was
broken before so the correction for this
Korona crash or whatever we're going to
label it as was the system fixing itself
and instead of getting out of the way
and allowing the system to fix fix
itself we just doubled down on breaking
the [ __ ] thing and for me when I see
someone who's supposedly you know as
intelligent or whatever is raised to
assume that these interventions are some
form of solution just baffles me because
that's it's not what we're doing like we
can't perpetuate that narrative because
all we're doing is running the same game
against like the narrative has to be
the the system is fixing itself by
correcting and we are breaking it more
by intervening not the opposite way
around and until we do that we're never
gonna fix it why do you think that he
hasn't at least publicly kind of crossed
the chasm and and said hey this Bitcoin
thing is real do you think it's that he
doesn't understand it he doesn't believe
in it or it's more of a sleight of hand
and actually he's doing one thing behind
closed doors and not talking about it
publicly yeah dude this one's won I've
battled with for a long time so I mean
most of the writing that he does like
particularly prior writing that this one
I think there was a lot of if you ask me
that question six months ago I would
have probably said it's the latter I
think that you know there's a bit of
sleight of hand going here and he's
buying our Bitcoin like a boss in the
background but reading this one I was
like you know man he's actually missing
a few really fundamental pieces like you
know intrinsic value being one of them
and you know presuppositions around you
know he's right about credit cycles but
he's defining everything within that
paradigm and you know he talks about
these paradigm shifts but he seems to be
unable to to acknowledge that bitcoin is
an example of a paradigm shift you know
or or a phase shift something that is
different to what exists so he's either
there's either something really really
really not clicking for him with respect
to Bitcoin or he's just because he's got
such a
I guess a public presence it may be
dangerous too
you know publicly promote Bitcoin
because I mean you know you got this
hundred and what is it two hundred
billion dollar asset now which I mean if
he turns around and says you know
Bridgewater is allocating to Bitcoin you
know we're probably gonna yeah we don't
need the having it'll be called the
Dahlia inning
Renaissance came out and said they're
gonna start playing right well the
market maker so they're gonna be less
buy-and-hold but still I think there are
definitely firms that are waking up to
what's happening here well there's
another example of that slowly and then
all at once right it's at some point the
game theory is gonna suggest that you
know everyone piles in and it's good
it's gonna be mental men when when the
actual that thinks thoughts to actually
happen
yeah I don't know man Dahlia is an
interesting an interesting case I feel
like you should know better but maybe
maybe doesn't other that listen we're
gonna find out for sure with with amber
you guys are not yet available in the
United States you're gonna be available
in your up soon for people who want to
find out more you can see what you guys
are doing around DC a the various
features that you've built where can
they go to learn more they can go to
amber app so a and B er app that will
redirect to our normal site which
actually get amber da da so we haven't
switch that's a new thing yet so don't
freak out when you see it but yeah amber
dot app all the stuffs there and then on
Twitter it's the amber app that's the
the tags of th ei MBR a double P so
that's a that's where people can find
out I would suggest we're gonna I'm
gonna release an article probably in the
next week or two once I get some more
solid dates around Europe so people can
keep track of when we're gonna be live
there I know we had a recent casualty in
Europe one of the dca services called
get bitter decided to shut down because
as you know
in the infinite wisdom of the Dutch
regulators they decided to introduce
some ridiculous new licenses which
basically made it unfeasible for get
better to operate out of Holland where
they were so unfortunately they're out
of the market so you know we're now
trying to make sure we can get in there
to to service people that were on that
are no longer able to be serviced in
Europe yeah I'm gonna leave you with one
question you have no clue then rations
what is the one piece of content or
writing that you wish somebody else or
yourself would write so what's the one
thing that hasn't been really heavily
scrutinized debated kind of laid out
that you say I would love to see ax
that is a I know what I thought you were
gonna ask me oh you're gonna ask me what
is the one piece of writing that I would
recommend his indispensable [ __ ] this is
a good question it's it's hard for me to
say because I I've recently just started
reading rough bub and just you know the
his libertarian manifest and it's
absolutely brilliant and I would have
said a real Eyck my answer to your
question would have been a whole
analysis on whether a completely free
market system with no governments is
actually possible and what that would
look like I would love to see something
like that but now that I'm reading this
book I see it's already been written 40
years ago so yeah I don't know man and
and so much good Bitcoin stuff has
already been written
i stumped you you you how much pride i
take in stumping people sometimes well I
will have to do a third one at some
point and you got to come with an answer
for that question
the reason I like that question is one
it draws on the ability for you to
understand what's already been written
which obviously you have and then it's
what is like the the intellectual
frontier that has not been explored yet
right it's really kind of what the the
question is asking and and part of the
beauty of those frontiers is sometimes
we know what they are right and so it's
it's very easy to say you know hey we
want to go to this place or we want to
do this thing but other times you
actually explore and discover by
accident right you know the kind of
canonical example is Christopher
Columbus he wasn't looking for for the
new world he was trying to get in Asia
happens to find this other thing so I
think that's part of you know but part
of the question but you know now that
you say that that there might be one
thing I could say with it and I'm sure
this has been explored but maybe
something maybe a modern libertarian
manifesto like Rothbard's
but using Bitcoin as the has the
the core piece of because Rothbard's
entire riding I guess is built on the
principle of private property and and
with that core principle he starts to
build all the rest of the philosophies
you know off the off the top of that so
you know maybe a more modernized version
of those philosophies but using Bitcoin
as the source of you know private like
real private property that are that that
can't be manipulated so that that would
be I guess an interesting thing because
I guess you could almost blend that with
the sovereign individual and Bitcoin and
sort of say like what would a future
look like where where the world
functions as a truly pure capitalist
free market
you know society where you don't have
the state you don't have these coercive
infrastructure that we have today and at
the core of it is these property rights
that are hard-coded into you know the
source of wealth Bitcoin and then you
have a voluntary society built around it
so it's about and maybe that's a really
long convoluted answer to your question
but I think that's something that has
that's probably I think where a lot of
the frontier thinking of Bitcoin is now
is like yeah yeah bitcoin is gonna go to
the moon it's gonna be worth millions of
dollars one day but what the [ __ ] does
the world look like when that actually
happens so yet maybe that's the area
that we need more exploration so let's
say I'm half stumped I Love You Man I
love it
let's um let's wrap up there I think
this was a great conversation I think
people found a lot of value in it and we
will definitely send some people over to
check out amber and then just keep doing
you it's it's always fun to see you uh
kind of putting those ideas out there in
the world and I think we need more
people doing it so a lot this again
maybe tours into the year first oh
brother
thank you for having me on again I
appreciate it